[Musique]
un homme demande à te voir
il t'a trouvé grâce à un contact
interpol un chinois avec une mallette et
un parapluie votre nom chen lo vous
cherchez quoi votre aide vous êtes les
meilleurs sur le marché
l'antre du diable demo la vérité c'est
quoi cet endroit à sa soeur terroristes
trafiquants l'hérault de l'humanité
oui tu peux m'aider sur ce coup là tu
auras besoin de moi moi j'ai mes seules
ses personnels à langer
- l'entrée liaison drone est acquis 40
prisonniers dans le secteur ouest
il dirige une prison secrète danger
maximale restez sur vos gardes
bonne chance on a de la visite en piste
tout le monde
hebron témoin soir le fils de mon ex
associé on n'échappe pas son passé
breslin
on va se retrouver
où tu vas
tu me connais je bosse mieux seul
souviendront de moi
j'adore ce bruit
quel dommage que tu sois pas là
ab
tu aurais pu aider mon père maintenant
je vais te briser
à temps
c'est ma vengeance
vous et écrasé la gueule
attendez à ces deux pour les hommes